[Musik]
wir nutzen das leichte schulflugzeug
daheim und dr
40 mg im zuge der militärpiloten
selektion und in der instrumentenflug
ausbildung und in beiden bereichen
überzeugt das flugzeug mit seinen
leistungswerten das triebwerk ist ein
umgebauter dieselmotor mit 170 ps damit
erreichen wir reiseflug
geschwindigkeiten von über 200
kilometern in der stunde die höchst
flugdauer beträgt über sechs stunden und
damit werden reichweiten von deutlich
über 1000 kilometern erzielt und mit
diesen leistungswerten ist das flugzeug
sehr gut geeignet um in unseren
gebirgigen übungsräumen hier in der
steiermark trainieren zu können